welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video are
breaking down the finale of Loki season
2 episode 6 is now out on Disney plus
and we've got a big video to talk about
Al Easter eggs hidden details and comic
book callbacks we also now know how this
sets up the future of the MCU and a
rough idea of where I could all be going
for the upcoming films I won't be
covering the Marvels ending in case you
haven't seen it but later on we might
give some theories for Deadpool 3 and
Avengers Secret Wars that will be all at
the end of the video though and last
week saw Loki getting the band back
together to travel to the loom in order
to stop it from self-destructing that
takes us into this episode in which we
get a lot of major Revelations for that
final time I'm going to need you to hit
the thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe because we have lots of comic
content coming soon but the way huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the Loki season 2 finale Loki
I'm watch you know let's assume I don't
know much but I'm a fast learner and I'm
a god well let's start at the beginning
now as always we begin with the Marvel
Studios logo however here something's
different rather than progressing
forward like we normally do we start at
the end and then work backwards this
carries on in one continuous shot with
it taking us from where the loom is and
then working towards the control room
this point of the Loom is very much the
goal in the entry and it's where all
things change at later in the episode
this opening shot reminds me a lot of
the one from episode 5 where we had a
journey through the TVA and then into
the void just adds so much to the
opening of this entry and we see lowkey
time slip into place Time Keeps On
Slipping slipping slipping into the past
and this is a different angle to what we
saw last week as we never caught Victor
going down the stairs this I believe
that that scene was from his point of
view with him looking up and then seeing
the God now the episode itself is title
glorious purpose and we see Loki
achieving this in the end Loki gets
himself a throne and all in all becomes
the man who would be king this is
mentioned by name later on in the
episode and shout out to Simon a bman
for pointing out its a reference to the
1975 Shan conry film The Throne is
something that he's wanted his entire
life and even in Dark World he said
something foreshadowing this all this
because Loki desires a throne it is my
Birthright the first episode of season 1
was also called glorious purpose as well
very much completing this entire Ora
boros now things don't go too well in
the open and we see his Victors killed
once more we then get A Fifth of
Beethoven with a montage of the music
constantly repeating over and over again
this music was used during Saturday
night fva and it's such a funky way to
add to the Montage aesthetic this
reminded me a lot of the ending of
Doctor Strange in which the dog ended up
using the time Stone to Loop his time
with Thor Mamu L he becomes what he does
at the end which might even explain why
the time Stone's green and as I've been
saying it's all
connected now realizing that by the time
I won't realizing by the time that
victor goes to the bridge it's going to
be too late ly then Time Slips back to
the war room to grab Victor earlier this
allows him to seem his minutes and get
things in motion for earlier but in the
end it's still not good enough love how
we can also catch the skin written on
the monitor which Mobius of course wrote
back in episode one Victor is killed
again and again and I don't don't really
feel like this episode fully hammers
home that Kang's a big threat maybe
maybe later on anyway earlier in the
season we of course watched the death of
Miz minutes
you'll never be
him in hindsight I kind of wonder who
she was talking about because she could
have been talking about K but also lowy
due to what we have happened at the end
now so far the series has been operating
on the bootstrap Paradox even down to it
being elements of the show's plot itself
I've talked about that theory to death
so I I won't bore you with it but it
basically involves a Time Loop in which
there's not really a start or an end
point what happens is the scientist get
some information from the future that
they then use to then help them navigate
the course of the present they then use
time travel to send this information
back to themselves so they can carry on
the loop that leads to them sending the
information back to them in the first
place it's something that dark worked
with a lot with the recent series bodies
also dealing with a similar sort of plot
device definitely recommend checking
them both out but the function of time
travel switched from that for this
finale here we operate with rules
similar to the butterfly effect in which
one's able to travel back to certain
points in their life time obviously
viewed in a linear manner by humans but
this theorizes that one's able to go
back to certain points in their past no
longer viewing time in a linear fashion
allows someone to go back to a certain
point in their life with the knowledge
that they then attained in the future
this is a similar thing to what Dr
Manhattan had and Watchman and also Amy
Adam's character and arrival now both
still has this cause and effect feeling
as knowledge needs to be attained in the
future to then go back and change the
past it's a lots of timey wiy wibbly
wobbly stuff and there's actually the
theory and quantum mechanics at the
Butterfly Effect won't change anything
and that time will heal itself anyway
that was something that was discussed in
Days of Future Past and in the end he
who remains may still come out on top
with this all being part of its own loop
at the channel we always get companies
trying to work with us you know we don't
do that many brand deals and that's
purely because I just want to pick out
products that I think you guys are going
to love and really enjoy using that's
why for this video I've teamed up with
age of sage you have these fantastic
absolutely love them these Amazing Star
Wars tumblers that you can get right Now
by clicking the link below they're the
perfect gift for a dad boyfriend husband
or just someone in your life that you
love and if they're a big fan of Star
Wars or the Mandalorian then you
definitely need to pick one of these up
they've got a ton of different ones on
the link below you know you've got that
Mandalorian one but you've also got the
last of us one Mario Hocus Pocus ones
and Mr and mrss ones that just complete
the whole set whether you're a tea
drinker you love coffee like me or a
wine connoisseur these are perfect and
they'll keep your drinks either hot or
cold for hours depending on your needs
they're also made with highly durable
stainless steel you know they're not
going to get any DS or breakes or even
crack open completely spell proof and
yeah really really good product that I
highly recommend you pick up it's also
got an UNS slippage bottom as well so
that's not going to spill over but what
will be tripping over is people looking
by going wow love that design cuz I
think that's absolutely brilliant so
yeah huge thank you to hsh for
sponsoring this video can't recommend
this product highly enough and make sure
you click the link in the description
below if you've got someone out there
who's a fan of you know Mario Star Wars
the Mandalorian Last of Us Hocus Pocus
whatever you want this is the perfect
gift and I guarantee anyone you buy this
for they're going to really appreciate
it find age of AG on Amazon and click
the link below for 20% off use the code
20 Galactic for 20% off and click the
link below to go through to their Amazon
store this is the way at this point ly
goes back even earlier to when they
first brought out the model of the Loom
OB is once again really embarrassed at
Victor seeing his work isn't amazing and
it's such a funny scene to watch they
kind of rep play moments of that scene
too but this time the dialogue's really
rushed a Victor this model is not
finished okay there's only one C of pain
on this now this model is actually an
Easter egg that we missed in episode
four there they said here's a model I
mark up of the Loom give the shy and
slash work but it's not too scale but we
could say that it was actually probably
better than this channel now this was
also referenced Back to the Future when
Doc Brown said please excuse the crudity
of this model I didn't have time to
build it to scale or to paint it I only
got one coat of paint on there I haven't
been able to cough our figures to
represent all of us good oh thank you
thank you okay I think you're being a
little hard on yourself it be it looks
great all right even though the lines
are the same everyone's kind of confused
about what's happening and they can't
enjoy it cuz they feel it's all kind of
a rush makes me think it's like what
happens when you want to just skip
through life but in the end you realize
he who remains with the friends you made
along the way at this point look you
realizes he need to learn in everything
that Obie knows and though it's going to
take centuries he ends up committing to
it a huge shout out to you guys for last
week pointing out the origins of Obie's
real name ad Doug not the dog now Ryan
AR On a related tangent Ryan AR pointed
out this is likely anoint to Douglas
Adams who was the author of The
Hitchhikers Guide to the Galaxy that
explained 42 was the answer to
everything and protocol 42 is what he
who remains used to wipe out everyone's
memories however this could potentially
be Arthur Douglas who in the comics was
Moon dragon's father though she was
introduced in Guardians 3 this may have
been an odd to where the high
evolutionary got the girl from Arthur
was also killed by Thanos which may have
happened at OB if he' remained on the
timeline ad is of course used in time as
well with us using it to date things in
opposite to BC his room looked exactly
the same as the TVA and he even used a
taser on Loki in the same way that a
pruning stick would be used by the TVA
now from here we C to centuries later
and see Loki guiding Victor into the
machine man's memory must must be
amazing cuz I can't even remember what
happened in last week's episode but Loy
remembers all the stuff he needs to it's
clear that he's also been through this a
lot of times before because he talks
about where he needs to tape the suit
this includes one of the crack parts of
the face play which Mobius also had to
do in The Season's first episode Victor
repeats the line time to be brave but
again this is kind of been fast forward
Loki's clearly learned a load too and I
love this bit watch out OB looks like
someone's coming for your job that's
right I'm a coming I'm a coming OB watch
your back just shows how much he's been
through and is losing his patience but
doesn't want to clue anyone into what's
really going on now look get this point
instructs Victor to hit the button but
it just won't work kind of reminds me of
what happens when I tell people to hit
the thumbs up but that doesn't happen
either like 300,000 views last time and
10,000 like likes what the bloody hell
is that now we appreciate it but this
shows that Victor isn't the right person
for the job and though it works the
struggle here H said it has to be
someone else this foreshadowing of lowy
taken over was even shown in the first
shot where we had Loki running in front
of the Statue of Kang his face then
studded a crumble and that's sort of
been a metap for for what's been
happening in the series Victor fires it
off and then manages to get back which
is when Victor says
Pumpkins this is actually 19th century
slang and it basically means to give
yourself a pat on the back however
unfortunately the loom still ends of
exploding which makes ly realize that
all those centuries were kind of for
nothing it needed to happen to get to
what we get but yeah just a kick in the
teeth to see it happen again now the
monitor Sparks up and we see that the
energy is also green which in itself is
of course one of Loki's colors I kind of
wonder if Green Lace throughout the TVA
for this reason with even the keyline pi
being that color too the branches then
expand due to a scaling problem and the
loom can't accommodate an infinitely
scaling Multiverse once more the loom
explodes and Loki ends up returning to
the Citadel where he tries to change
things we get a sort of replay of the
scene before the time slip takes him
back but but he's able to change what he
says he then States the last thing I
want is a throne Sy stop which I we
we'll say about that I love how he
remains is just kind of cackling in the
back and he constantly says see you soon
which was a Taun that he used in his
dying breath a he remains is still in
his a mortis get up which is a last
known version of K while Kang's
eventually become a Morse and the comics
could hint to us exactly what happened
moris eventually brought all the council
together and gave the idea that they
were to stand as united front however in
the end that was a lie and he
done all this to be able to take them
all out at once so him wearing this
makes a lot of sense and I think he's
the real am moris rather than the one in
Quantum Mania now in the elevator he
also sees Loki put away his sword which
kind of tips him off that something here
has changed that's very much what we're
seeing here with the loop of season 2 or
being part of the plan just in the same
way that episode one had roner
explaining the Avengers were always
meant to change time Loki was pretty
much always meant to do this can we get
some to po did a graphic of how the show
works and what we have is season 1
Ending by creating this loop the loop
itself was always meant to happen but
its eventual outcome was always going to
be that it ended with Loki going back to
this point from here things would then
change and then be able to continue to
what we have in the show now shout out
to joshia Denim nerds who predicted this
was all going to be an illusion this was
because the floor in the Hologram made
it look like it had a triangle whereas
in the real room it was a NECA square a
NECA square is an optical illusion which
confirmed everything this is and the
battle itself is a really big thing for
the show and I love all the action that
we see happening the sword throwing
magic it's all spot on and season 2 sort
of been a mirror of season 1 we had Loki
and both arriving at the TVA and not
really understanding what was going on
they then team up with their variant and
bombings would happen carried out by
nefarious head in episode 2 next we'd go
to a location before a character was
pruned and sent into the void Mobius was
pruned in episode 4 which was was
married by Ravon on episode 4 of season
2 that would then end with a big
Cliffhanger with episode 5 showing us
that it was not as it seemed finally
episode 6 would culminate at the Citadel
and the show's just been so well
structured when Loki asks he he remains
why he doesn't fight back he then
realizes that he's been through this
before and finally stops things in order
to confront him just him kind of mocking
him with him also stating that he paved
the road this is something that he said
in season 1 and our survey says that
that it was him now a survey says is a
little joust that he puts out and in the
UK that would be referencing the show
Family fortunes think in the US it's
called Family Feud though but you you
American peeps come on come help a guy
out with his breakdown let me know if
that's wrong and I'll be the British
Loki guy and you can be the American he
who remains now if you've been enjoying
the videos for the past 6 weeks and want
to help support the channel then make
sure you pick up our Loki inspired
t-shirt on our merch store below this
contains all our latest designs like our
classic movie breakdown one as well and
it's the best way to support heavy
spoilers we also have the join Button as
well which is basically our patreon that
will get you access to some of our
videos before anyone else also I've been
told to tell people to stop going to Ace
Cafe and using the code Ace spoilers to
get 50% off it was a joke mate it was
just a joke don't go to Ace Cafe and say
ace spoilers I won 50% off cuz you're
not you're not going to get it now he
who remains also talks about
reincarnation baby which is the same
line he had in the season 1 finale he's
really the and it's with this that Loki
steps up to the plate reveals it isn't
the first time that he's been through
this stopping time he shows that he's
mastered it with he who remains warping
Sylvia out of there he who remains sees
all and mocks Victor's stutter and talks
about the fail safe of the Loom we
discover how the loom actually works
with it just deleting the branches that
aren't supposed to be there except for
the sacred timeline I feel like he who
remains is already encountered ly before
and that he's seen him kill countless of
his variants my variants are already up
there I won't stop doesn't matter never
stopped me before I know CH I feel like
what we might get in the end is that
Loki will either go to to Toe with him
either in Kang Dynasty or potentially
during the events of Secret Wars either
way the outcome of the equation Remains
the Same but the outcome to this
equation remains it Remains the Same I
love how he repeats the word remains as
well with this letting us know why he
always wins at this point Loki sees the
equation on the wall and he says that
he's going to break things
however Loki doesn't seem willing to
make the tough choice as doing this will
ruin all his happy moments and Destroy
his friends too not even the sacred
timeline will be safe but Loki promises
to find another way at this point he
remains brings sby back which gives Loki
the option to make the hard choice and
from this point we go back to episode
one of season 1 and we catch Loki in the
time theater him returning to this was
actually foreshadow last week with him
time sipping to he before he then moved
on these were all important locations
throughout the characters his lives with
his also being a defining one for him he
promises to claim his throne again tying
back to that line from Thor the Dark
World now on the desk we can see a can
of jtic cola which was an old Cola brand
that then went out of business obviously
the TVA have access to all time hence
why Mobius is still able to sip it and
this sort of turns into a therapy
session but obviously we're still with
the season one Mobius he's still
indoctrinated and is just pruning
because he thinks that's the right thing
to do Mobius tells him the story of
someone who was responsible for 5,000
deaths in the Black Sea going to prun
him he then discovered it was an
8-year-old boy and it's very much a sort
of would you kill Hitler as a baby if he
could go back in time thing the kid was
just hanging out with his brother and
the hunter refused to make the tough
choice and thus things went arai in the
end we learn Mobius was that guy and I
think the two boys made him stop because
he has two sons though he's not
conscious of it something's clearly
buried away which explains why he also
has a fascination with jet skis though
was memory was raised you can't change a
person's nature and it's such a telling
thing for Mia's character now as partner
who did it that's definitely raona and
we did see in the past how she brought a
young sylv in however she too hesitated
and let her go and this Butterfly Effect
very much brought about the events of
the Season her being a teacher that may
have been what stayed her hand and again
you know she she had a relationship with
children so it it does show it's buried
in her subconscious realizing there's no
Comfort though and that you choose your
own burden low he then slips to the end
of episode 5 where he starts to change a
lot of things he stops reality falling
apart and takes Sylvia outside of time
and this is so the PE can have a very
deep conversation he tells her that the
Looms designed to protect the sacred
timeline and that she has to die so she
can't kill he who remains in the first
place sort of like the grandfather
Paradox with ly realizing that there's a
hope that he can replace things with
something better now the idea of Loki
being in control was actually
foreshadowed a lot throughout the season
even back in the first sent we watch
just Lu who was trying to rationalize
why he who remains was doing what he did
to kill the devil maybe he was calling
him the devil he also pointed out that
he was sort of a better the devil you
know leader though he Stripped Away free
will the other option was far far worse
Kang's multiversal War would ravage
across every reality and lead to
trillions and trillions of lives being
lost due to the amount of destroy
timelines that'd be Loki's always been
the perfect candidate to become Loki
hero remains and him taking of the role
was even something he argued for at the
end of season 1 selie ended up killing
he who remains and kicking lucky back in
time but Lucky's Choice was always that
obvious on top of that Earth 616 Dan
pointed out on our last video how
similar lucky was to K when dealing with
Don he promised to drop him back at his
home the moment he left so he could be
with his kids again this is similar to
how Kang promised shanet he'd return at
a h if she helped him out in fixing the
multiversal chair thing both of them are
kind of deals with the devils and these
fan offers of course never really played
out the way that you'd expect Janet
would have had to allow Kang to wipe out
countless timelines and in the end she
wouldn't have even ended up with her
hope at this point he Wars back to the
end of episode four and he decides to be
the one that goes out on the walkway
also huge shout outs to Simon again for
pointing out that the saying on the wall
for all time always broken down to its
acronym fatter in Latin means Destiny
now the reason that Loki can survive
this radiation is purely because Loki is
a God even things like Infinity War show
Thor could survive out in space and due
to their density and lifespan it's very
difficult to kill them which we've seen
with Loki hundreds of times at this
point and this shows that it was always
meant to be his Destiny and explains why
he's worthy whereas he who remains isn't
I was made for this now this bridge
itself also somewhat hints to Loki
leading as it even resembles elements of
the bifrost the bifrost is based on
Asgardian designs which this two also
has itself Loki himself had a
transformative moment on Bridging the
first Thor and now it's coming full
circle to capitalize on that walking
along we see his clothes strip away but
he changes into this new kind of God
suit this was actually spoiled on the
season 2 poster giving us a clue of
where things were going to go this time
the crown resembles the cracks of the
Citadel with it being fused together
through using kin sui this is an ancient
Japanese technique of using crack potery
together and it could also show that he
was a smash statue at the Citadel we
never learned who this was but having
Loki there that would have course
spoiled everything tearing the loom
apart this then spreads out the Strand
which Loki starts to them pull together
these act like the roots of a tree and
from here Loki creates the world tree
this all connects to nor mythology and
tree imageries being shown throughout
the season even the male vent that led
into Obie's room that sort of looked
like a trunk heading up into one tearing
up its Doorway to the Citadel at the End
of Time Loki then decides to give
everyone a chance I feel like this is
taking Loki to become the god of stories
and potentially even on the Avengers
Prime Arc ENT of Asgard heavily
influenced the show as it was a major
point boki in the comics in which he
shifted from villain to Hero The Source
material had him as the god of stories
in which he ended up leaving the
Multiverse completely and going to avoid
outside of time and space here he
encountered not only those who sit above
in the shadows but also an elderly King
Loki who'd been throwing things through
time to try and control his past God of
stories ended up telling him that due to
his actions he'd actually changed things
with him too and had propelled him from
being a stepping stone into becoming a
new kind of Loki this was a major change
in the character that vastly altered him
and they are sort of ripping off that
here last week also took a heavy focus
on fiction and fiction itself is of
course based around stories on top of
this we discover that Hunter B1 15's
name was veryy Willis and that two was a
character that popped up in the comics
now Avenger Prime is also someone who
exists far far out in the future and
he's also been controlling things in the
the past two in case you don't know fog
is now the one who's in Creative control
of the comics and it's sort that he's
slotting things into those to help set
up things for the MCU this includes
Avenger Prime who could become a major
part in the upcoming stories like Kang
Dynasty and also Avengers Secret Wars
their identity was teased for ages and
then it was revealed in the end that
this was actually Loki and masked in
Avengers forever 12 it was discovered
that he dipped into the Multiverse and
had learned things of the Avengers
defeating him everywhere destroying them
S created several major multiversal
threats that the Avengers would have
defeated in their own reality thus he
had to collect the Avengers from other
timelines and this was in order to write
the wrongs of the past now I know that's
not really what's happening here but the
basis for it could be used in the future
now from here we jump to the TVA after
and see the tree poster that's been
spoiling this entire ending every time
we've seen it this tree iconography is
also shown in the mural of the
timekeepers which the timekeepers stood
around and helped to grow life at the
TVA that's been turned on its side which
we also see in the branches too Mis is
there but they're trying to trust her
and they're keeping an eye on the he who
remains variants this includes one that
they say is 616 adjacent with a seeing
shots from quto Mania we told that they
handled it and thus the TVA doesn't need
to step in this confirms a theory that
we had in our last video which is that
the majority of the show was taking
place before Quantum Mania Avengers
endgame was the moment in which Loki
slipped out of the time stream and after
being caught by the TVA he spent what's
about two weeks going on the journey in
the show thus even stuff like no way
home is technically happening after this
series with the Multiverse opening up to
allow the Council of kangs to them be
created this is all ushered in the
multiversal war without playing out in
secret Wars with Kang potentially at the
center of it I know there's Rumblings
that he might be replaced by Dr Doom due
to that Variety article and hey I think
that that could be the case too in the
comics both Secret Wars events were
sented around Dr Doom and he ended up
stealing the power of the Beyond or
Beyond dur depending on what version you
read this made him into a guard in which
he was able to bend reality to his well
when the Multiverse was destroyed Doom
ended up putting together Salvage pieces
of it into one planet called battle
World along with his ally Doctor Strange
he was there when the beyonders were all
destroyed and there was even talk that
had Doctor Strange stepped up that he
could have been the ruler I think that's
where things could end up heading but
we'll talk about that more later on in
the video now on his desk we see that
Mobius has requested a file and though
they wanted take the time keeper murals
down they remain who remains up mobia
says those who don't uh wow don't
remember the PA wow and uh this is the
beginning of the phrase though who those
who don't remember the past are doomed
to repeat it this is normally used to
describe war and heinous acts carried
out by Humanity with it often being used
to describe the outcomes of fascism the
TVA once stood as a fascist organization
but now they're trying to do better and
remember the past either way we learn
that Mobius is leaving which shows that
Loki actually kept his promise in
episode 5 though he gets off of the
chance to be a judge he goes back and
hey I'm I'm not crying you you cry n
Mobius doesn't really know anything else
unless he's scared but he still decides
to go back we see the war room is now a
buzzing Hive of Staff with it showing
that things are now more open than just
having one ruler above all the official
TVA second edition is then released with
it being a golden yellowy color instead
of the orange one that was before was
trying to think what this might
represent I couldn't might figure it out
but if you know then please drop it
below now back with Victor he never got
the buck and raona then wakes up down in
the void over in the corner she looks
over at a pyramid in Sphinx which could
be henting towards her teaming up with
Ramat this was a Kang variant that was
the Pharaoh in Egypt and we see the
grass move out the way to reveal this is
where the TVA once stood I think that's
how I interpreted it anyway and it
seemed to me that the Citadel was all
that remain of it and maybe it was
pruned and sent to the void it could
show roner escapes though and maybe
eventually we'll see her destroy it
either way we see as a lith arrives and
the creatures a big changer from how
they're in the comics The Source
material had him as an even bigger
conqueror of time than Kang was with his
temporal domains stretching back
billions of years this was all the way
up to 2000 BC which was a temporal point
that Kang refused to go past this is
because it would have brought him into
conflict with elith who up until that
point ruled over it all though he's
presented almost like a lap dog here
there may be more of the character with
him potentially even being banished to
the void so K could conquer more time
now I feel like ravona may end up
conquering elith and she could use it as
a way to get out there's a determined
look in her eyes as it gets closer and I
don't really think that that looks like
fear now raona in the comics was a big
love interest of Kang with her playing a
major part in developing the character
that's something we've seen in the
series with the info that we've got and
she also sort of follows her later
iterations it actually got to a point
where ronner ended up turning against
him because of all the pain and misery
that he Ro across the Multiverse and
only myself left to conquer he loved her
when he was a young Nathaniel but she
was then killed by an older version of K
this then sent her Essence out into the
time stream where she was reincarnated
again and again through time no matter
what happened though their love was
doomed and the pair were always unable
to actually be together sometimes she'd
be killed and other times she'd betray
him leading to Kang becoming depressed
and bitter in the end he encountered his
younger self and murdered her past
versions to to start the cycle again
here we've seen Ron and a girl from a
loyal and devoted soldier who helped to
win he who remains his time War but then
got betrayed since then she's been
running the TVA but it's been a
thankless role with her being cast out
of the kingdom of heaven so he who
remains can rule alone in many ways she
could even be a flip on Lucifer and
there's definitely lots of biblical
imagery lays throughout the show season
one saw he who remains carrying an apple
and loking Sylvie will like Adam and Eve
now he watches Mobius goes back to his
old home which is where he he's then
joined by selie they're seeing the
Perfection and imperfection and this
brings things full circle from what she
said to him in episode 4 she said if he
never looked he'd never know but now
he's ready to stay and watch over his
life super sad like super happy as well
and I'd be lying if I said there wasn't
some dust in the room making my eyes Go
funny now as for Sylvie we don't know
where she's going to go but we cut to
loky at the end of time on his throne
holding it all together a tear passes
because of what he ended up giving her
but now my man has a very glorious
purpose unfortunately there's no
mid-credit scene and no season 3
confirmation but I think we will
definitely be seeing these characters
again now before we get into what's my
predictions I want to talk what I've
thought about this series as a whole I
know viewerships been down early 40%
since that first season premiere but I
genuinely think this is the best MCU
series out there I've always been
fascinated with time travel and I think
that this has mastered so many Concepts
and used its storytelling beautifully to
weave them into its narrative the
bootstrap herox has been used
brilliantly without and even though this
sometimes makes stuff predictable
there's been so many C balls throw and
it's been difficult not to marel at it
put intended there's also just a step up
in production that's happened with the
series I really noticed this watching
season one and then going into this but
the way the camera moves is a major step
up just adds so much dynamism to the
scenes and I actually think this helps
with the Panic that you can see a lot of
characters going through plus the acting
is topnotch and it's a really well
crafted time story that I think makes
the most of its Central cast of
characters though the locations and
characters they are a bit limited it's
woven together really well and at points
even feels like it it's part of a stage
play this reminds me of a really
well-crafted Doctor Who story stretched
out for six episodes and yeah one of my
favorite series so far in the MCU
obviously uh but I really really enjoyed
it now as for where the MCU goes from
here we have the Multiverse Saga coming
into full effect with a number of
upcoming titles
again I won't spoil the Marvels in case
you haven't seen it but if you have Mt
has a big video breaking down what
happened in that on the channel right
now you can click it at the end of the
video though either way the next major
project we know we'll be tackling is
Deadpool 3 this will take a heavy focus
on the fox franchise and it will be
bringing back a number of actors
including Hugh Jackman's Wolverine from
what I've heard he's going to play a
major pod in secret Wars 2 and that's
going to have a number of returning
actors in it as well that'll be Toby
Maguire the major X-Men cast Robert dowy
junor and potentially even Chris Evans
Avengers end game was a big celebration
of the MCU and Secret Wars is sort of
going to be doing a celebration of all
the Marvel movies from across the board
this includes the things that Marvel
Studios didn't even own but Disney's
been doing the big moves and buying up
all the studios that own these classic
characters so finally they can bring
them in for that big movie and you know
I know there's a lot of MCU fatigue at
the moment but I think everyone's
probably going to be seated to see that
from there it's been said that there'll
sort of be a reboot that then creates a
new universe out of all these older
franchises into one streamlined timeline
that was what happened in the comics 2
with characters like Miles Morales being
brought into the 616 I think that we
could even see a sort of Avengers Prime
happening with Loki in which he goes
around recruiting The Avengers from
across the timelines man can time slip
at will so we could see him going
throughout all the realities to get who
he wants to help fight in this
multiversal war ultimately I think that
he who remains will likely come out on
top and then we might start to see the
cycle begin again but this whole series
has been about breaking cycles and this
has been seen right across the board
Loki originally was a villain that was
used as a stepping stone to propel
others to Greatness but he's even broken
this along with the cycles that we've
seen throughout the series such a good
way to take things the matically and I
hope you've enjoyed us going through the
series really means a lot to me that you
watch us cuz there's so many great
channels out there making brilliant
breakdowns massive shout outs to screen
Crush hack Dogma den of nerds new rock
stars emergency awesome Mo from streamer
real rejects Canadian lad everything
always Cosmic wonder and basically all
the people who've made talking about
this show so fun also huge shout outs to
Mt who joined our team back in August
man's really brought an incredible
amount to the channel and I think his
analysis level it it's it's completely
Next Level anyway huge thank you to him
and huge thank you to you guys again for
everything and please drop a like on the
video as it really helps us out I'd love
to hear your thoughts of course and if
you want something else to watch we've
got a video on screen right now that's
going to be going over all the stuff
that happens in the Marvel so hopefully
see you over there right after this by
the way huge thank you for sing through
the video I've been Paul I'll see you
next time you take care peace